will those in favor please raise their
hand a unanimous vote in the U.N
security Council this is likely to be a
landmark moment for the people of Mali
the U.N mission menusma is being closed
it's been in Mali for 10 years
174 peacekeepers have lost their lives
in that time the ambassador of France
which withdrew its own forces from Mali
last year says the mission was not a
failure so now we will clothe the
operation but I don't want to be
explained that it's a failure I think
the UN did a lot it was a major effort
by the International Community the plan
now is for all 13 000 peacekeepers to
leave the country before the end of the
year in the council meeting the Malian
Ambassador says they'll make sure the
U.N stick to that timeline
not the government in Mali will be
vigilant in ensuring compliance with
these engagements as a responsible
government the Malian authorities are
committed to closely cooperating with
the Secretariat of the United Nations
and manusma in the framework of the
prompt implementation of this resolution
within the established time frame but
Western Nations warned that Mali which
will now rely on the Russian mercenary
company Wagner is making a big mistake
the United Kingdom would not have chosen
to withdraw manusma at this moment when
Mali and The Wider Sahel are facing
increasing instability and humanitarian
needs
and we do not believe that partnership
with the Wagner group will deliver
long-term stability or security
the U.N has a responsibility to minimize
the risk that its assets fall into the
hands of those looking to destabilize
Mali or bring harm to its people
including violent extremist
organizations in the Wagner group
normally when the UN withdraws a
peacekeeping operation it's because the
situation in the country is getting more
peaceful but the U.N must now pull out
its troops and equipment in Mali where
there's still a conflict raging and
there's an added complication the UN
Secretary General Antonio guterres has
issued a statement saying he's concerned
about the level of financial support
he's getting for the withdrawal from
member states he says it will add to the
complexities and risks in the months
ahead James Bay's Al Jazeera of the
United Nations